alright let's have something more
concrete to work on if you've organized
events you've probably used sites like
amitabh calm and eventbrite com well
let's say you wanted to create an app to
organize conferences that type of
application would need to support at
least the following as user can register
as user can create conferences users can
attend conferences and of course it
needs to be accessible both from the
browser and the mobile device well we're
going to create such an application and
it's going to be called conference
central and your task to build it and
since it needs to support multiple
backends you will use Cloud endpoints to
create this application let's get
started with conference central by
having you download the skeleton code
now let's take a quick tour of the
completed conference central application
that you will build but before we do
that let's do a quick demo of the
finished application as you can see
you're presented with a very nice
landing page for conference central and
if we scroll down you can see options to
view conferences create conferences and
update your profile but before that that
sign into the application sign in will
use Google+ sign-in once we assigned
into the application we can start to
explore the functionality I can for
example go to my profile where my
personal information is stored I can
also show the registered conferences so
here you can see the name of the
conference the city where it will be in
the start date organizer how many people
registered to the conference and how
many tickets are available to the
conference you can also query for
different conferences for example the
ones you've created or the ones that you
will attend you can also query by other
types of properties and you can view the
details for a conference you can also of
course create new conferences well
that's an overview of conference central
the application that you will build and
run in the Google cloud now it's time
for you to do some work and get you
started building conference central good
luck